now it is Latin America's turn to face
the pain of the kovat nineteen storm
that spread west across the globe in
Brazil the Health Service is
ill-prepared in truth it's already
overwhelmed they know this they can't
fight this virus
they're digging thousands upon thousands
of graves in the city of Sao Paulo
more than 13,000 a planned medical
workers haven't given up hope but there
is no battle no real war here they're
facing defeat in full hazmat gear the
grave diggers and burial teams struggle
over the freshly dug earth grieving
family members follow behind this is a
funeral of Jose talavera he was 52 years
old he died after a few hours in
hospital the authorities say it was Co
vyd whose son Philip II insists it
wasn't there is a stigma to this disease
and there's no testing anyway every
family is allowed five minutes at the
graveside every five minutes
there is another burial the graves are
separate but the dead are covered over
on mass to all intents and purposes this
is a mass grave across the world a
phenomenon of this virus is always the
same everyone dies alone
marceline de silva saw her brother enter
hospital that was the last time you take
a piss off my dad saw them quizzical
fetus apiece and so remain today we are
going to progeny
Chima vez que vienen aquí la tropa de
interés now within the bottom eyes al
you myself
they've been digging graves here
non-stop for the past two weeks they're
doing about 800 a day the workers
thought they'd have been done by now
that they've been told to keep going
tomorrow businesses Roberto martini Yuji
Torres a Spokane tebron iscope as
possible year
[Applause]
Brazil's president Jeb Olsen arrow is
still dismissing this pandemic as a
light flu he's wrong of course but it's
irrelevant what he thinks anyway they're
dying here in huge numbers and it's
nowhere near the peak more countries in
Latin America are going the same way
Sturm see Sky News